well
rogue um
this is never easy but um
i'm [ __ ] canning you
what sugar and as a happy by-product of
your termination we do lose that
annoying southern charm you're firing me
because of my accent oh yeah you wish
insurance is through the roof and having
an unintentional energy vampire just
going around touching [ __ ] it's not
gonna work for the next quarter
look
i've been a good friend of this team
yeah too good on many occasions how many
times do i have to send someone to the
infirmary just because you couldn't
resist a kiss
i can't have people dying just because
you're lonely
you can't touch people
stop it
if i couldn't touch people i'd wear oven
mitts and a t-shirt that says death upon
touching you wear like sexy boots and
strut around it's not my fault oh
there's something i can't remember about
what i'm supposed to do and not do so
why don't you come over here under the
willow tree and give me a big wet kiss
on my honey honey lips
whoops you're dead
right that's it how do i keep forgetting
that i mean i wish i could control my
powers and i wish i could walk is is
wish time
how long does this go
are we done with the aladdin just found
the genie moment because wishes don't
come true unless the wish was to get
your ass out of here in which case it's
christmas
if you do see hair dye man go ahead take
the glove off and touch him and let him
die because i'm tired of the whole bride
of frankenstein thing high five
jk it would kill me
don't worry though i'm sure you can get
work being a bonnie rate look alike at a
shoe store opening in a mall
i can kill you with my mind